now is the attorney for whistleblower
Gary shapley Tristan Levitt he's also
the president of Empower oversight
Tristan uh your reaction to that
reporting specifically this this
allegation that your client was the one
breaking the law
clearly utterly ridiculous on its face
and we've seen this throughout that
those are the kind of threats the hunter
Biden's legal team made last summer
Chris Clark told the prosecutors even
before this threat to put Joe Biden on
the stand the charging Hunter Biden
would be a career killer for them and
he's trying what he can to make it be a
career killer for our clients as well
and so it's it's unfortunate but it's
not a surprise at all it's clearly has
no grounding in fact and in fact the
judge up in Delaware Mary Ellen Noriega
noted that because the pleadings from
Hunter's legal team had asked that
chairman Jason Smith's Amicus brief
giving further details about the West
Florida disclosures be removed from the
docket because they claimed that again
there was grand jury or other
information there that shouldn't have
been and judge Noriega really smacked
that down saying that making such broad
allegations was irresponsible of them
what is your client saying now that we
know that they actually wouldn't even
probably have asked him for the guilty
plea at all had they not come forward I
mean imagine if they didn't come forward
so what's his reaction been
well I think there are several key
points that have stuck out to Gary first
off is that knowing now what was
happening uh between the prosecutors and
the defense Council really adds a whole
new dimension for the investigators they
were cut out from the meetings that the
prosecutors had with defense counsel
which seemed unusual to them at the time
now we know about all these interactions
specifically the threat to have Joe
Biden testify came at a really important
time and I think it's important for your
viewers to understand that letter was
sent on Halloween in 2022 and that
letter came at a time when uh a sister
when U.S attorney David Weiss was about
to have the 2014 to 2015 tax charges
including a felony for 2014 for making
false reports on his income taxes about
hiding his barisma income those were
about to expire the statute of
limitations and Weiss had a decision to
make and so I don't think it's a
coincidence at all that Chris Clark is
writing to Weiss and saying hey we would
put the president on the stand at a time
when he's making a decision about
whether to let these barisma charges go
so I think that's very significant the
other thing that I think really stands
out to the investigators is that this
more than anything abundantly
demonstrates why there should have been
a special counsel appointed from the
very outset of this investigation and so
you know it should have happened earlier
the fact that even then at that moment
they should have immediately appointed
him one well but the also the idea that
we've we've discovered the presidents
using these pseudonyms
to communicate the jrb you know all the
uh all these these whether it's their
acronyms or pseudonyms to disguise his
identity why would you do that if it was
just a friendly conversation between
Father and Son
I mean that also gives more Credence to
what your client and the whistleblowers
have been saying all along that this
needed to be delved into seriously by an
objective prosecutor with no political
ties none
absolutely and what you see instead
looking at the information that Senator
Chuck Grassley has put out there from
unrelated whistleblowers is that when
this information for instance about the
fd-1023 from the FBI alleging the that
barisma bribe not only Hunter Biden but
Joe Biden that being presented to the
Delaware U.S attorney's Office the IRS
agents were cut out just five weeks
later the same assistant U.S attorney
that received those allegations was
telling investigators you can't ask
anything about the dad I mean this
investigation was hobbled at hamstrung
from the very beginning because people
refused to see what was right in front
of their faces
well remember Tristan Garland was saying
early on that that Weiss had a complete
Authority that he had a broad you know a
birth a wide berth in which to operate
and that clearly is not the case
no question and what these articles also
revealed was something that's very very
significant which is that less than five
weeks after Merrick Garland swore to
Congress in fact to Senator Grassley
specifically that there would be that
Weiss would not have any interference by
the justice department you see that an
official from the deputy Attorney
General's office responded to an inquiry
from Chris Clark who's trying to get
anyone at doj to say where to go if
Weiss charged him and so for a deputy
attorney general official to set up a
meeting and join the meeting with Chris
Clark and David Weiss clearly shows that
Merrick Garland's testimony to Congress
was just not accurate Tristan great to
see you thanks so much hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else